on certain TV shows crime scene
investigators seem to do it all they
interview suspects and analyze clues but
that's not what real CSIS do senior
investigator John Kerry and his team do
one thing and one thing only
we are very specialized our job is
specifically dealing with the evidence
going into the scene collecting the
evidence the work John and his crew
perform creates the basis of the entire
investigation if they smudge a
fingerprint or don't perfectly follow
procedure or if they contaminate the
scene the whole investigation can be
thrown out of court and a criminal could
walk free thanks to TV crime scene
investigators have to deal with what
they call the CSI effect when they
testify in front of jurors if it doesn't
match up with what somebody saw on a
television program which they now
believe to be the way to conduct it and
they may feel that we did not do our job